this video is sponsored by dollar shave
club use the link in the description for
a special five dollar starter set
on february 28 2017 you might have
thought the internet was down
four hours without netflix spotify
buzzfeed reddit dropbox pinterest imager
league
tinder and thousands of others even the
site that reports outages
that's embarrassing if the world was
more productive that day
now we know why our slash outside became
just you know
outside a shark hadn't bitten an
underwater cable
nor was it five nine just an amazon
engineer's typo
probably a stressful afternoon in
seattle but also an impressive
demonstration of the company's
size and power amazon web services host
so much of the internet that for many
people
myself included it basically is the
internet we know amazon as an online
store
companies store their products in its
warehouses which handle the marketing
and shipping and returns for us this
means total convenience
one click away from 125.27 pound gummy
bear pythons
or five crisp two dollar bills for
twenty dollars
wait that's not how money works a
hundred thousand companies make over a
hundred thousand dollars a year this way
but for amazon it's only a fraction of
their business
there's also twitch whole foods kindle
alexa sensibly named echo echo plus echo
dot echo dot kids amazon tap
echo connect echo spot echo show and
echo look
also a completely different alexa fire
tablets and tv
prime music video pantry ring doorbell
zappos imdb
fresh goodreads and over 70 consumer
brands you'd never even know
they owned hardly a month goes by where
they don't enter and dominate a new
industry
just trademarking the slogan we do the
prep you be the chef
was enough to drop a blue apron stock 12
they're even investigating
pharmaceuticals education
and finance amazon defines its
competitors as publishers producers and
distributors of physical digital and
interactive media of all types and all
distribution channels
among others that's like everyone which
raises the question
is amazon scatterbrained many of these
products have nothing in common
yesterday they wanted to conquer
streaming video today
sell organic grapes in grocery stores
tomorrow who knows
and their ideas increasingly let's say
creative
to day delivery how about two hour
delivery
a 3d smartphone a grocery store without
employees
a front door that unlocks for delivery
drivers a flying warehouse complete with
detachable drones
for all its success as an online store
more and more
it also seems distracted at least that's
how it looks
the only way to make sense of their
actions and mistakes and anticipate
their future
is to see the world as they do and there
are three pillars to amazon's plan
for world domination to really
understand
amazon you have to understand jeff bezos
like steve jobs or elon musk the
philosophy of the man is that of the
company
apple was founded by people in love with
technology and its design
no matter how big the company gets this
will always be reflected in its
decisions
priorities even mistakes amazon began as
a bookstore but that was never its heart
and soul
or spine bezos chose books because no
one bookstore could hold
all of them warehouses visited on the
internet could but make no mistake
they aren't a book company a website a
delivery network or
even a retailer amazon is a scale
company bezos understood that when you
take something and multiply it a hundred
thousand million times you can do things
all the small businesses in the world
never could a tree is a tree but put 400
billion together and you have the amazon
rainforest a force
so powerful it controls the world's
climate
from any other company this sounds like
generic business speak but amazon
really means it we say a company is
focused if it specializes in beverages
or cars or bad website design and puts
all its xp into
that ability amazon is rare and that its
specialty isn't the product itself
but its scale that's the focus when
considering a new product the flowchart
is pretty simple
would this benefit from being a thousand
times quicker bigger easier
if so you can bet amazon either sells it
or soon will
it's easy to stop there sit back and
enjoy the profit but amazon asks
okay now what can we do and this is why
it's unstoppable the snowball effect
first get as many users as possible give
out 50
tablets free shipping license echo to
every company
willing more users bring more data which
helps improve the product
and the better product attracts even
more users they aren't just making it
easy to live off
amazon they're making it hard not to
that's the power of data in the hands of
someone operating at this scale
it's why there's now a movement to limit
this why companies like digime who i've
previously mistaken for a data
collection
company actually let users manage and
safeguard their information
and the results are things like prime it
may lose money on the heaviest shoppers
but with a hundred million of them
they're winning a lot more than they're
losing so why purchase competitors like
whole foods
exactly because it's not what they're
good at books never expire
well some do but groceries not so much
you have to go back repeatedly
putting amazon in your routine and with
so much shipping
spending 11 billion fulfilling 300
million packages in 2015
they can do something almost no one else
can compete with ups and fedex
they already lease 32 boeing 767 cargo
jets and plan a massive cargo hub in
kentucky but that's just the beginning
after announcing a new 79 kindle bezos
wrote there are two types of companies
those that work hard to charge customers
more and those that work hard to charge
customers less
both approaches can work we are firmly
in the second camp
and he's really not kidding the parts
alone cost 78.59
plus 5.66 for assembly that's a loss of
5.25
for every kindle sold not including
things like marketing
licensing and support and sure there are
ads but only as an option
companies like facebook and youtube are
fundamentally advertising companies
no matter how well-intentioned youtube
employees are
unless something drastic changes the
company will always prioritize
advertisers over creators that's the
business model
and then there are customer companies
where you and i decide what gets
demonetized
apple is comfortable charging more for
the very best experience
and for amazon helping the customer
means making us pay as little as
possible
both are loved in a way that's
impossible for an advertising company
you might say
they only care about the customer to
make more money and
maybe you're right there's no way to
know but the effects are the same
when apple refused to unlock the san
bernardino iphone when amazon takes a
loss for the sake of our wallets and
offers some of the best customer support
i've ever
had it may only be a calculated business
decision
but it's great for us of course when the
customer comes first
everyone else comes second employees can
easily be forgotten in this never-ending
quest to satisfy us here's how bezos
describes it one thing i love about
customers is that they're divinely
discontent their expectations are never
static
it's human nature we didn't ascend from
our hunter-gatherer days by being
satisfied
this is the hedonic treadmill no matter
how much our lives improve
our expectations simply adjust almost
any other company would resent this
constantly having to improve their
products even the rate at which they
improve but amazon
embraces it they're just as discontent
as we are except if there are billions
to be made by concentrating on scale and
customers
why can't anybody else do the same how
can a tiny online bookstore do something
exponentially better than walmart
the world's largest company by revenue
it's easy to think of a ceo as the
supreme leader of a company but even
bono has a boss
in this case shareholders the longer a
company loses money
the greater its risk and the more
anxious get investors
but for amazon lack of profit isn't just
tolerated
it's celebrated they could stop and make
a dollar
they'd rather wait and make five using
profit from things like aws
to fund projects like kindle and echo
because bezos is so open about this
shareholders sign off and they can think
far into the future
those cargo planes not so cheap but that
doesn't stop
amazon supermarkets operate at a one
percent profit margin but amazon can buy
whole foods and actually lower prices
it also gives them freedom to experiment
the fire phone was never ready for
prime time but that's a small price to
pay for this strategy
moviepass snapchat uber spotify blue
apron
all starving companies following in
amazon's footsteps
crossing their fingers money will come
later ex-google ceo eric schmidt says
amazon is already google's biggest
competitor
aws competes with google cloud echo with
google home
prime and express youtube and twitch
even search
a company this diversified will face
plenty of challenges
a lot will change in 10 years but will
always want
low prices fast delivery and easy
shopping
as amazon conquers one industry after
another
they may only have one real competitor
the government
who may say do not pass go and do not
collect 200
profits may be shaved but you and i will
always be able to shave and comfort with
dollar shave club they're more than just
razors toothpaste body wash wipes hair
styling and more
everything you need to look and feel
great i can tell you it's all very high
quality stuff
and i especially like how simple it is
everything is delivered right to your
door
without the hassle of going shopping and
it's affordable
new members can sign up for just five
dollars you get a trial of their
executive razor
body cleanser wipes and shave butter at
this kind of price
you can see what you like nearly
risk-free replacement cartridges are
sent for
only a few bucks a month and if you're
picky like me you can choose exactly
what you want
when you want it you're never locked in
and you only pay for what you need
no membership fees or anything like that
get started for only five dollars and
help support polymatter with the link in
the description
dollarshaveclub.com polymatter thanks to
dollar shave club and to you for trying
it out